casas y carros calcinados son casi lo
único que queda de la pequeña ciudad de
klamath el river la mayoría de los
residentes huyeron cuando las llamas
acercaban pero algunas familias
decidieron quedarse como roger de ree y
su hijo
cuando el fuego llegó a ese punto había
llamas de 30 metros a lo largo de unos 8
kilómetros cuando el viento soplaba y
hacía que el incendio bajara como un
soplete sólido no había nada que lo
detuvieran no fue intenso pero es verdad
es muy triste es muy descorazonador
algunas de nuestras casas más antiguas
casas de 100 años han desaparecido
con el tiempo se reconstruirá pero va a
llevar algún tiempo estamos realmente
devastado la red de bebés este de
mckinney comenzó pocos días después de
que otro incendio oak amenazar el parque
nacional de yosemite
provocando la evacuación de miles de
personas
es el mayor incendio forestal en el
estado en lo que va del año y las
autoridades están instando a la gente a
evacuar las zonas amenazadas por el
fuego
siempre que haya alerta de evacuación
creo que la gente debería seguir ese
consejo y evacuar esas zonas vimos un
comportamiento intenso del fuego de
viernes a domingo así que si le piden
que evacúen siga el consejo aún quedan
varios meses de intenso calor y sequedad
en california por lo que la temporada de
incendios está en su punto álgido